foreign
comes from Christine in Virginia she
says what is the difference between a
bear market and a bull market and why
are they called Bull and Bear I don't
know how to take these into
consideration when I'm investing that's
a really good question I feel like you
hear that a lot
um it's basically the terms to talk
about when the market is up versus when
it's down right it's like the 20 swing
between it being up and things looking
great and everybody's like optimistic
and happy and it being down which it had
been
better part of 2022 and even into 2021 I
believe and everybody's like oh no we're
all dying
and it's a bear Market which you know
I've always I don't know if I'm right
about this but I've always just thought
okay it's a bear Market everything's
asleep like it's hibernating the good
stuff's hibernating well I read a I read
something that said that it's based on
the two animals are based on how they
attack you so a bull
like bores you with his horns up right
and a bear slashes you and goes down oh
I don't know I've never heard that I had
never heard that either that's why I
shared a little bit I was more with the
run you know bull in a china shop yeah
you know run crazy yeah and charge right
and uh the bear is hibernate yeah cold
yeah so a bear is an extended down
marketables and extended up marketing
that's right short amounts too and it
shouldn't change if you're in baby step
four it shouldn't change anything about
the way that you're investing
um you invest when the Market's down and
you invest when the market is up and
that's just part of it and over time it
balances itself out and you know that's
called dollar cost averaging yes when
the Market's down the shares are on sale
oh God the stock market's down when
people say that I go oh great the stock
market's down they're on sale yeah and
so it's like get get it you know you
know flash sale on Friday they're down
you know jump in get get while the
getting's good that's right and when
they're up it means that all those
shares you bought are doing really good
so there's always something to be happy
about if you think of their proper
perspective the only reason you freak
out when the Market's down is if you
think it's going to stay down forever
which there's no historical debt I mean
historical there is some hysterical but
there's no historical data that
indicates that there's lots of
hysterical data that indicates that so
let's talk about I have an angle that I
want to discuss this all right so let's
say you are you want a dollar cost
average which is you're just putting
that same amount you know month after
month or whatever if you are a person
with irregular income
what's the best way to automate that
like we talked about we've talked about
before just like automating these smart
habits what's the best way to automate
that if you're not sure exactly what
your income's going to be
well I mean you'd have to automate an
amount that you are sure about
because otherwise you gotta change it
every time but then at the end of the
year
you'd have to do it make good yeah you
got to make good a couple times a year
yeah and look up and go I gotta play a
little ketchup if I'm going to put in if
I think I'm gonna put in twenty thousand
dollars and but my income is very
volatile I might automate 10 000 of it
or 15 000 of it and then do the make
good on the other five and that's when
this has gotta not shake you you've got
to not go oh the Market's not is down
I'm not going to put in this yeah you
got to keep going you gotta you gotta
stick with a constant consistent
investment plan
all the research all the data of the
people that jump in and jump out they
don't keep up with the constant people
that's right you can jump in jump out
jump in jump out some because you're
using way too much emotion a hundred
percent of the time when you jump in and
jump out that's right and you're not
using good data and you're not doing
good long-term thinking
you're using freak out as your
investment advisor and don't use freak
out freakout's a bad investment advisor
well that's one of the reasons that it's
good to have an investment advisor to
help you not be the Freak Out
exactly so you don't fall for that the
dollar cost averaging is simply if if
the the shares that you're buying in a
mutual fund are down because the
Market's down then a thousand dollars
that month or a hundred dollars or two
hundred dollars that month whatever it
is buys more shares that's right they're
down it buys fewer shares when the
shares are up and the Market's doing
well but the shares that you already own
are worth more so it's like a sale so
you end up with you know that you end up
with the benefit of having ridden the
roller coaster that's right you got the
thrill and you're perfectly safe
everything's okay so it's all good no
one gets hurt on a roller coaster except
uh those that get uh those that jump off
in the middle that's all that is